is Nick Swisher here that's good to see
you man insurance thank you my man
appreciate is my pleasure to do that is
my pleasure how is life for you you're a
dad twice over yeah we really like you
left the the baseball career in the
rearview mirror how I look right now
it's amazing you know what I it's funny
because you you do something for so long
in your life yeah and then all of a
sudden you don't do that anymore
yes and it almost kind of uh you wonder
yourself like it I wonder who I am now
yeah like does that define who I am and
luckily for me that I got a lot of other
things in life that I enjoy I feel like
I've got the greatest family on the
planet hottest wife I mean like the best
is in the world why wouldn't I want to
be at home with them right um I feel
like I've been fortunate enough to maybe
have a little bit of a personality that
people enjoy listening to so I've been
able to do the Fox stuff the NBC Spartan
thing the ultimate team challenge that
came up and I could not have been more
honored to be there just to be as hyper
and as loud as I wanted to be so for me
man I could not be more blessed of where
I'm sitting right now
when did you realize though that it was
time to maybe turn the page was there a
moment and at bat again I feel like
right after I had my double knee
surgeries at the end of 14 it just
quickly went downhill from there man
like I didn't have that same wit man I
couldn't pop the hips like I used to
with the Indians yeah just in general
man and it sucked because I had just
signed that awesome contract they did
myself like oh my gosh I get paid this
much to play this game that I love right
and then the injuries start taking
effect and one-one great year at 13
there and then 14 is kind of a struggle
year and then after that man it's just I
just didn't have it left I tried to make
a comeback to the Yankees and Brian
Cashman gave me a shot back down there
and triple-a and and I'd say after this
after the birth of our second daughter
sailor just being at home and I said to
Joe one night I said yeah I can't go
back like this is this is where I want
to be and I've always kind of thought I
was I wasn't with those guys it would
just be like hanging on to a career you
know like when it was time to cut the
cord it was time to cut the cord and
immediately after that I was so
fortunate enough to get some some
amazing jobs and so amazing
nick swisher here in the Rich Eisen show
studio who's the best player you played
with like yeah I know you played with
the tunnel yeah I've heard like just
right on top of my head just the captain
man Derek Jeter just not even
necessarily about the numbers but just
the way he carried himself and just the
things that I learned from being around
like what what you learned I just feel
like you know the game now is is is with
fantasy sports and things like that
there's so much emphasis on individual
players I think the one thing I learned
from him the most was swish you show up
and you play to win the game each and
every day like he didn't matter to
Onofre floor or fourth before you played
to win the game and help your team win
and it's so crazy that you know I know
there was a lot of comparisons this year
with you know Girardi saying judge was
kind of like Jeter but I feel like when
you have one of your superstar guys that
literally in every interview he does
talks about wanting to win the game that
brings back in my mind kind of like that
Derek Jeter vibe well we had Michael Kay
on the show last week and I asked him
who is Aaron judge like who is this kid
how how well screwed on his shoulders is
his height okay real good I what he said
and he mentioned Jeter mentioned he goes
you know I don't want to kind of put it
on him but in terms of the guy he talks
about his teammates anytime it he's
asked about his own individual
achievement yeah that he comes in and
and he conducts himself in a certain way
and that he's kind of locked himself
away you know here he he doesn't want
all that attention man he wants the team
to be the forefront and to be able to
have I spent three months with all those
guys in triple-a when I was trying to
make my comeback that right who like and
so like you've got my dirty sanchez talk
my ear judge ben gamble over there in
seattle Chasen Shreve in the bullpen for
the Yanks and i was so lucky fortunate
to play with with all those guys because
at that time taking ten hour bus rides
and 35 years old was like the worst
thing in the world you were like bull do
well crash yeah man the boy ever let me
sit in the front I had my own like
special cool respect good Christian days
yeah but at that point man ten hours on
a bus man with my knees the way they
were that time it was like it was
automatically they're off the next day
but you could tell it at that point in
time the judge had it because because
man because like at this point Thomas
man's hitting like you know he's hitting
you know three four five in our line
like 260 265 yeah he's hidden some
moonshots but like not on a consistent
basis the way he is now right and the
one thing I always noticed was back then
he he was really really tall he was six
seven in the box yes now he's about six
floor in the box who's a little more
squaddies more into his legs and just
watching what he's doing right now man
it couldn't be more proud of nick
swisher here on the Richard show you
mentioned Jeter and then obviously in
2009 so you got a front row seat to see
the Jeter a-rod bromance bloom oh yes
and that thing bloomed to the full all
the way to to the CNBC chair that was
what you think of hard to watch thank
you it really was right I mean let's be
honest it's very difficult oh yeah oh
yeah and now you know the interview just
walked right into it
thinking that they really were I feel
like they kind of got high I feel like
they got set up for that that was the
guy who set up for that well I mean I
think Derek started off I think he
thought it was something different and
then I think it turned into that which
that is that's bad on both sides you
can't take two two guys like that and
you know what you're doing well well I
don't think they knew what he was doing
I don't think CNBC knew what they really
the the reporter announcer human he
started jabbing a little bit but in all
seriousness because I know that a-rod is
a colleague of ours now with Fox and
like doing a wonderful job that is that
is but how much there is there to that
the Jeter you know I don't know I feel
like you know I feel like you've run
into guys along your career we're
talking about two iconic figures like
that you know um who knows man I mean I
I don't know what happened before and
it's okay but Nick you think you guys
they're geared more here's what I'm
gonna give you I'm gonna write on a
piece of paper here on right okay
I'll write on this card right here you
may use this at any point during the
interview and say that word go ahead not
if that's the word you want to say right
back give this card back to you get one
more interview may use it at any time
blink twice your face a visitor hey why
should this feels awkward but I guess in
that respect - is that when you're
because it's unlike any other sport you
are on top of each other
104 162 games in seven eight months this
and that in that regard yeah so how much
does a quality Clubhouse come in anyway
yeah me I merely receive like if you
know me you definitely know where I
spend there there has there has in my
mind has a lot to be said for a cohesive
unit like a cohesive locker room like
people to get along and I can use an
example right now
please you look over and seem like the
Detroit Tigers with the amount of talent
that they have in each and every
position all across the field haven't
found a way to put it all together yet
with that sort of talent you feel like
you should be you should be winning ball
games a lot and then you might take a
team like the New York Yankees who might
not have well with the way these guys
are playing right now feels like they
got superstars at every spot this year
but there has there has a lock there has
something to be said for like a tight
group of guys I mean I know the Houston
Astros what about the Milwaukee Brewers
right now sure well they're hitting that
walk-off home runs how much fun it
looked like these teams are having right
now what's wrong with the Cubs I don't
know him I don't know I feel like Joe
Maddon's going to do what he needs to do
to make it happen I really think so
later you Fred I know I'm a huge fan of
his I feel like I'm always going to have
his back I just think he does what's
right for the game and by the way this
is not that it's not that the Chicago
Cubs in 2016 the Chicago Cubs in 2017 so
what what's missing here brings
different problems well I mean obviously
looking at the number if you could say a
couple guys are having some bad years
but remember they're playing the NL
Central so there's no real stress right
there I in my opinion Chicago Cubs no
stress definitely going to get to play
in the postseason and you know I believe
that if you get hot whatever team gets
hot in the postseason is what
everything's gonna win Nick Swisher is
here on the Rich Eisen show we'll talk
about Spartan ultimate team challenge
when we also come back there was an
incredible first time moment on the
diamond that went down yesterday I want
to hit you on that and then also there's
something that's going on between me and
one of the members of the Chris command
center over an Instagram posting on had
I posted a shot of my bare feet I've got
a problem with that okay it's a man code
violation I figured who better to ask
than you and you can also use the pass
wow I'm a house whipper guy okay this is
good
okay Nick Swisher when we come back here
in just a second on the rich
nick swisher of fox sports and also
nbc's ultimate team shouts Parton
ultimate team challenge here in studio
ever have a a cycle no sir no sir what
was your best biggest walk-off moment um
what do you got for me on that front I
think it might have been you know the
day after the boss and Bob Sheppard had
passed away we were playing the race at
home in New York and I hit the game tied
home run eight and then getting would he
knock in the night - it was a walk-off
home where the walk-off single which
I'll take breath sure no way it was such
an emotional day that day so for me
that's something definitely after
Steinbrenner and Bob Sheppard passed
away um you know I'm a die-hard Yankee
I'm growing up from New York City I'm
born in Brooklyn raised in Staten Island
a Bob Sheppard who by the way also guys
I know if you where he did the PA for
the New York Giants for many many many
many years as well just so yep so that's
that iconic voice sounded like god
itself now panting what was your number
in number 34 number 33 Nick Swisher
number 33 yeah and it always really did
the number time well it's funny because
even after he had you know after he had
even stopped you know working for the
Yankees and hold on yeah Derek Jeter
brought his brought that so every time
he would hit number two yeah they would
still use that I know and they still use
that on the S network they sometimes you
can hear Bob Shepherd's voice like he's
so entranced with just that traditional
non like a yeah all right not a lot of
voices out there like that
well we're speaking old gen there's an
old gents that we don't do
next-generation stats here on the Rich
Eisen sure we do old gen stats Ural Ford
go for it Michael Oh Jen
Nolan Arenado became the sixth player in
Major League Baseball history to hit a
walk-off home run in a game in which he
hit for the cycle Carlos Gonzales of the
Rockies was the last to do it rehab so
the Rockies have now had the last two
such home runs right the one before that
Dwight Evans Dewey Evans did it for the
84 Red Sox George Brett did it for the
79 Royals sees our Tovar did it for the
1972 twins and the first to ever do it
was ken Boyer of the st. Louis Cardinals
back in 1961 but Nolan Arenado is the
first infielder with a cycle and a
walk-off home run since George Brett did
it 1979 knows your old gen stats from
all that stuff we have no idea we have
no idea what that song isn't it music is
there anything like that every old good
while we polished we figured we should
say that because your dad Steve there a
farmer nine games officially going over
there got my father-in-law Jay so you
got you guts all year to hold some other
stage yes father's dead ever yesterday
man so you got your in-law you got your
dad I got everybody dude kids look at me
bro we're all renters and you're like I
appreciate that we are all rest there
than the next wisher I are definitely
having a blast right the only thing I
kind of don't like about use why'd you
go to Ohio State I know what I held in a
while about ah I believe scarlet gray
well I feel like my greatest answer for
you would be that's the only school that
recruited me okay that's okay I don't
take that I was a robot ever late
bloomer well you know late bloomer so
what would November's be like with Jeter
I mean cuz you know yeah you know we
could economist you know jeez not we
always said we were going to go to a
we're going to start making that Ohio
State Michigan game yeah a big game for
us and we started golfing together this
off we don't have off seasons anymore
that's the sort of winner every day
every day yeah so you know we started
golfing together so I feel like we might
have to start making that happen okay
you know just just let me know I'll I'll
tag along that's what I said this is my
thought well you know if you want you
know go ahead and tell
what I refer to Derek Jeter go ahead go
ahead don't I don't care go ahead the
most perfect human being ever belong I
feel like you would be saying the
correct dance
I don't know again now removing family
members people that you have come across
Nick Swisher right who's more perfect
human being than dirt you let's be
honest here be honest
could be deadly honest III if you're not
already go I don't need a pilot I don't
need to be I feel he's such such an
ambassador and was so great for the game
of bass gave a baseball yeah and
continues to be he does he will be an
iconic figure for I mean he's almost
he's almost before he's a living legend
almost I agree with you and the Astros
destroyed his night within five minutes
flat
oh yeah Tanaka didn't have a good night
that no he did not
yeah you're going a papi night on Friday
right I'm going to a Big Papi retirement
nighttime Friday okay that should be
some special it's a copy luxury pretty
great Robert I just loves life just you
know I feel like for him me you know II
wasn't scared to say nothing that may I
can get away with anything you want to
get away with it Boston now I pretty
much you're talking about the Derek
Jeter of Boston right
our Derek Jeter's the David Ortiz in New
York I agree
but either way don't agree an asset well
you had a lot of agree to that but I
definitely made their city's home to
them you like deep in there which is
something to be said no but uh no lon
like I ended the curse your hold on a
second excuse me you're sitting in the
dugout right New York Yankees Red Sox
right Bloods boiling yeah I mean this is
it this is a rival right this is it is
you are winning this game there is
alright and poppy smokes one half way to
Queens right out of Yankee Stadium
see that and then and then takes 50
seconds to run around the bases you're
not saying anything in the club in the
clubhouse the Duggar no come on
well I feel like at that point Tom I
feel like that you got to know who David
Ortiz to know why David Ortiz plays the
way David Ortiz played because number
one like no one's going to say nothing
to David Ortiz he can do whatever he
wants understood but you're not in that
Clubhouse muttering at that brother or
not I don't think so because I don't
think the I don't think that run around
the bases would get me the home run not
what would have got me you can't you
can't do it to the Yankees from obvious
Oakland and then the White Sox Oh Jeter
is already a big figure of course going
to you how do you approach that first
like meeting and then meeting him and
then also like do you ever ask the
question about the gift basket thing is
it is not are you ever come that was
kind of what the first day I walked into
space ready I looked up on the wall and
I saw like Mariano and Pettit actually
like a-rod and cheered I'm like oh my
gosh am I really here right now and I
don't remember much about the gift
basket bag so okay you didn't have to
say the word pass hope you get that
comfortable with what I wish I remember
much but I don't miss okay so put up the
Instagram photograph for Nick Swisher
Nick I posted this over the weekend it
was a nice moment Father's Day where I
got to put my bare feet up and take a
photograph of a rose a bottle and a
glass of rosettes on a table is that
breaking a man code we'll eat I don't
think so thank you Nick Swisher you're
right ma'am I'm sure like you you got
some nice shade on your feet right that
helps a lot imagine our look boys if it
was the highlight of your picture I feel
like we would have an issue okay but
it's not the actual glass of Rosie is
the highlight of the picture correct
right
yes so if you don't know you like that
Nick you're saying you're saying if if
there was a paste eNOS to it then you'd
have a problem so if you brought your
ashy unman occurred toenails into the
party room and it was there was if it
was brighter yes that would be a problem
I think instead this is a work of art
I'm actually thinking myself like wow
Bros that's your crib what UK yeah I go
me I like an infinity pool cruising on a
definite understanding but what's your
take on the Rose a was a rose a because
that was a conundrum hosting more I'm
more of a I guess I'd be more of a vodka
guy okay you know but I can appreciate
it can hang okay
Nixon Hank Nick and Hank what's the
aspect of this Nick that people are
going to eat off of that table and his
probably not freshly-cleaned feet are on
it um
like a kitchen table uh no not a kitchen
table but it is an outdoor eating area
uh I feel like we're like a couple these
guys just fight for the table I think
you might have been all right
you've already antes DS the verdict is
in you lose and I win Nick Swisher I
feel like y'all I feel like we've seen
some some dirty feet like Shaq speak
yeah something like that right um yeah
al exactly my father looked at my feet
were nicely pedicured or as a caller
into the show said I should refer to it
as foot treatment which I got it's got a
great foot treat mystery right because
you know I mean you guys in Major League
Baseball you got to get pedicures and
manicures you can't walk around art from
the ground up guys straight to do so
tell me about your experience with
Spartan ultimate guys I was so honored
and fortunate to be part of this this
season too because if you got the
opportunity to watch season one which I
think you should to get a little bit of
background on exactly what Spartan
racing is this year is kind of a an
evolved version of it come to instead of
like rolling hills and lots of running
lots of distance between obstacles this
is a more of a compact shot in an
abandoned factory so it's got that steel
mill kind of vibe that gritty still got
the Spartan mud we've still got things
like the Spartan throw but it's more of
a condensed ultimate adult playground
just with obstacles that you've never
even seen before so for myself to be on
the sidelines and literally watch these
men and women do these obstacles yes I'm
thinking to myself like number one wow
really glad that I met the guy that
designed these to actually teach me how
to get over these things because I'm
wondering to myself how do they even
know what to do because I like these
people see these obstacles there are
some from from last season but season
two is so awesome and it shot so well
and the stories are the biggest thing I
mean everything from War veterans to
amputees to people that have lost family
members that have bonded over a sport
like this it was an honor for me to
highlight their lives
I'm so glad that you got that gig what
you're doing with Fox Sports and you and
your beautiful wife Joanna good people
man
thank you Robert having good people stop
I'm always I'm always up for and come
back any time I've had a blast your
message I've been coming in so dull for
ever in here come back any time
seriously we're here at my house is
yours oh my god Nick Swisher is here I
don't regret saying that and you also
did not use your last pass so you can
have that when you come back in Nick
Swisher here on the Rich Eisen show
studio we'll come back and set up the
rest of the week and check on anything
else that's gone on and the rest of the
sports world over the last half of the
Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern
on radio stations across the country and
audience if you like that download our
app please just if it's a memory thing
just delete other apps you don't need
those apps this app the Rich Eisen show
up you need that